Today might
be the start of a
pretty volatile week on Wall Street
will get key readings on the U.S.
labor market.
Also testimony, two days of it
from the Federal Reserve
chairman, Jerome Powell.
The Fed will announce its decision
on interest rates a little bit later
this month.
This, of course,
follows eight
consecutive rate hikes
going back to March of last year.
Also over the weekend, notably,
Federal Reserve President
Mary Daley of the San Francisco Fed
said in a speech
this weekend, quote, It's clear
there is more work to do.
Suggesting that the Fed
will need to raise rates
higher than expected
and keep them higher for longer.
But what does it mean for you?
Former Treasury Secretary Larry Summers
joins us now,
someone who has been spot on
when it comes to the risks and inflation
for a number of
years now,
warning the Biden administration
and others of what is to come.
So, Secretary Summers,
thanks very much for your time.
It wasn't just Mary Daley of the San
Francisco Fed.
It's also the Minneapolis Federal Reserve
president, Neel Kashkari,
who we've had in the program,
Atlanta Fed Chief Raphael Bostic.
A lot of warnings,
including the warning from
Fed Governor Christopher Waller.
Do you think the Fed is going
to need to increase
interest rates more than expected?
Maybe it's 50 basis
points at the next meeting this month.
Look, I don't think there's
any question, Poppy, that we do not yet
have inflation on a secure glide path
anywhere near down to the 2% level.
And until the Fed
can be confident of that,
it's going to have to be tightening
rather than easing.
So my guess is that
rates are going to reach a higher level
than the market is now expecting
that it's going to certainly reach
a much higher level
than the Fed was expecting last December.
And that once again,
the data will record that the
Fed underestimated inflation
and underestimated
how much policy
was going to be necessary.
That's a
risky thing because historically,
we don't tend to be able to engineer
soft landings from significant inflation.
And so my guess is that at some point,
the Fed will push and push.
We will not get inflation
accelerate and skyrocket out of control.
But my guess is that the process
of bringing down
inflation will bring on a recession
at some stage
as it almost always has in the past.
How much higher?
Larry, I mean, are we talking 6%?
Look what Goldman is saying right now.
I wouldn't be amazed if we had 6%.
6% would probably not be
my best guess.
My best
guess would probably be five and a half
or a little above five and a half.
But 6% would not surprise me greatly.
And I think anybody
who thinks that that's off
the radar
screen is making a real mistake.
Given all the uncertainties that we have
in our economy
right now,
and I think what people have to do
is just be prepared for a lot of things.
The old advice.
Hope for the best,
but plan for the worse,
I think, is the right advice for
your listeners.
I think
it's the right advice for companies,
is the right advice for policymakers
like you.
JPMorgan CEO Jamie
Dimon has also been warning about
what's ahead, especially
when people deplete all that
COVID stimulus savings.
Listen to what he said.
This was on February 23rd on CNBC
the US economy.
This is the contradiction here of the US
economy right now is doing quite well.
Consumers have a lot of money.
They're spending it. Jobs are plentiful.
That's today out in front of us.
There's some scary stuff.
And you and I know
there's always uncertainty,
but that's that's a normal thing.
Okay.
This uncertainty is a little bit
more than that.
Do you agree with him?
This uncertainty is more than normal
and there is some, quote,
scary stuff ahead.
And if you do agree,
what does that feel like
for the average American
Poppy, I've used the term
risk of a widely coyote moment
to refer to the fact that the economy
could hit an air pocket in a few months.
My guess is that the overhang
in the savings
that consumers have accumulated
has a few more months to run,
but it doesn't have another year to run.
Businesses seem to be long on
inventories right now,
businesses are holding on to workers
because there's been a labor shortage
for the last couple of years.
But if that starts to go away,
then they're going to feel less pressure
to hold on to workers.
It may be that interest
rates are going
to eventually work their way
through the system,
and that's going to have
a significant effect
on employment, for example, in
building houses.
So you've got a variety of dynamics
that could kick in.
I thought it was interesting
in a survey of households,
they said they were feeling
really quite good now
and they were worried about the future.
And when you ask
some of the big retail companies
when they reported their earnings
like Wal-Mart,
they said something quite similar.
So I think between the risk of inflation
and the risk of
some kind of air pocket,
the Fed is trying to walk along
a very, very narrow ledge.
And it's not an easy situation.
Know it's a tightrope.
There is no question about that, Larry.
Summers, thank you.
And we'll see what
members of the Senate and the House ask
Fed Chair
Jay Powell when he testifies this week.
Appreciate your time this morning.
Our chief business correspondent,
Christine Romans here to break it down
there.
They're calling it
hell week on Wall Street this week
because there's so much happening
and it's all really important.
You've got a Chair Powell
going to the Hill for a couple of days.
You got a bunch of different jobs
statistics until we get to Friday's
jobs report.
You've got the president's
going to drop his budget
blueprint on Thursday.
So there's a lot that matters
for your money happening this week.
And one of the big issues
here,
I think, is a very strong job market.
And that is something
that has been a problem for the Fed.
We're expecting the job market to be
maybe 200,000 jobs added
in the most recent month.
And you can see, remember last month
how strong that number was.
So the job market continues
to be very, very strong.
And we expect we're going to see that
again this week.
So why
why would a strong labor
market be bad news for the Fed? It's
because the Fed
has been
raising interest rates
over and over and over again,
and it's not cooling off the job market.
And that strong job market
could continue
to spin off more inflation
and the Fed is trying to cool inflation.
So it just shows you
the Fed might have to keep interest rates
higher for longer.
We know that there are two to jobs open
for every person who is looking for work.
That is a really, really tight
labor market.
That chart right there shows you
that the Fed might
still have a lot of work to do.
The Fed would like to see things
cool off a bit.
So we have a strong job market,
great for Main Street,
not so great for Wall Street.
Well, and also really kind of shows you
the power
or lack of of the Federal Reserve
when it comes to these interest rates,
because if they're not
impacting the job market,
are they having any impact?
And I think that's
what you're going to see.
The Fed chief grilled about this week.
You're going to hear him.
People on the Hill are going to say
you're going too hard.
This is hurting working families
are they're going to say
you're not going hard enough
getting inflation under control.
So I think he's going to be criticized
on both sides.
But we can see where
where the Fed interest rates
have been working in the housing market
that has slowed,
but also credit card interest rates.
And I think this is really the takeaway
for four kitchen table economics here.
Credit card
interest rates are at record highs.
19% for a typical credit card,
up to 30% for a store card.
If you put
$2,000 on a typical credit card,
you only pay the minimum balance at 19%.
It would take more than 12 years
to pay it off
and you would have 30 $200
in interest on that $2,000 That is just,
that is just more interest
to initial spend, more interest
in the initial spend.
And on a store card it's even worse.
So I think that where you're seeing
the higher interest rates
really working through
the economy are places like that.
And that's
where people have to really be careful.
I think Caitlin makes the point,
which is the medicine's not working
enough.
The Fed medicine on interest rates isn't.
So what does that mean? The Fed have to.
What else can we do?
Do they raise it to 5%, the target rate?
Do they raise it, as Goldman
Sachs suggested, closer to to 6%?
That means higher rates
for longer in the economy
and higher rates are to know
if it would work in
higher rates
is something that that that real people
in working families feel.
Meanwhile, the job market is strong
right on its surface.
That should be good news.
The job market strong.
There are a lot of jobs open
for people out there.
Even with these headlines
in in tech and in finance of layoffs.
Overall, the job market is strong
and you still have very
few layoffs every week. Okay.
Going to be economy, as always,
hell week by week.
Thank you very, very much.